تدفع اكثر من مليون يورو للحكام جوكوفيتش
يسر على موقفهم من لقاح كورونا وسوبر
ماريو يظهر في ملعب بنيويورك هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
قبل نحو شهرين من نهايه الدوري الانجليزي
دفعت انديه الدرجه الممتازه نحو مليون
ونصف مليون يورو كتعويضاته للحكام بعد
تصريحات المدربين او مسؤولين الانديه التي
يهاجمون فيها حكام المباريات وسجلت
الرابطه الانجليزيه اكثر من 100 مخالفه
على الانديه كما يعدوا ارسنال متصدر
البطوله هو المتصدر ايضا في المخالفات بعد
دفعه نحو 250 الف يورو نظره احتجاجاتي
وتصريحات مدربه ولاعبه
لا يزال جوكوفيتش مصرا على موقفه بعدم
تلقي لقاح فيروس كورونا وهو الامر الذي
كلفه الغياب عن نسختين من بطوله امريكا
المفتوحه للتنس واعرب النجم السربي في
تصريحات صحفيه عن امله في تخفيف اجراءات
دخول الاجانب الى امريكا بدءا من شهر مايو
المقبل للحاق ببطوله فلاشنك التي تعتبر
الاهم بالنسبه له لكنه في الوقت ذاته كشف
بانه لا يشعر بالندم على قراره بعد خسارته
للكثير من النقاط
وفي مدينه نيويورك اختار فريق ان يجرب
الشاشه العملاقه الجديده الملعب عبر تشغيل
لعبه سوبر ماريو وغرد الفريق عبر حسابه
على تويتر متسائلا ان كان قد وفق في اول
تجربه على الشاشه الجديده وهذا في اخر
استعداداته قبل انطلاق البطوله الوطنيه
ويعد مات سوى الفريق الثاني للمدينه في
لعبه البيسبول بعد النادي الاشهر نيويورك
يانكيز